joining us on youtube this evening
welcome to our full council budget
special meeting
we don't have a chair or vice chair this
evening as they've both given apologies
which is why i'm starting the meeting
off so if i could start
we need to elect a chair for the meeting
so if i could have nominations for a
chair please
check out what chief said could i
propose coaster leather for tonight
please and as they say for one night
only
any other nominations
are there any other nominations
so we take the
first proposal recommended first which
was that counselor leather the chair for
this evening's meeting
could i have those in favor shall please
those against
come to the next
[Music]
uh
thank you everybody thank you fellow
councillors for electing me for
i think as a leader said well it's only
one night only as if thank goodness it
is always a lot nicer but thank you for
that
and the chief execs welcome the members
of the public and those are reviewing on
youtube to the meeting very important
meeting this budget special full council
so we'll start with the first item on
the agenda
um
apologies for absence please
sorry yes chair cancer christie
councillor bushby
councillor brown
penciller ford and councillor dart
thank you
item two on the agenda is public
contributions we do have
well three three members of the public
to speak tonight
um
mr robin glover he's here if you'd like
to come up and use the microphone please
and when you settle you've got three
minutes to address the cancer that
should be a bit quick
thank you
good evening everyone uh many thanks for
allowing me the time to talk about
victorian park
my name is robin glover i'm local
businessman and i've lived in biddeford
all my life
i lived by the park for the last 10
years and witnessed the decline in play
area facilities for the children it
seems that over the years there's been a
lack of investment in the provision of
new equipment and the maintenance of
existing items
i've now worked in insurance for over 20
years i've had numerous clients that
provide clay equipment facilities to the
public these customers were not being
able to operate facilities they were in
the states
that were in this stage of repair i
fully recognize it must be hard for any
council to prioritize where public funds
are spent
rather than take to social media to just
complain about the situation i thought
it'd be best to try and assist the
relevant councils so we can all work
together for the good of the town and
its residents
this is why i decided to form the
victoria park community group
the idea of this group has tremendous
opinions from local people and ways to
improve the facilities that we already
have the park is a massive asset to the
town and it's really only the play
equipment that lets it down
there is also a lack of equipment for
people with additional needs
i've been in dialogue with the northern
the northern care trusts who have given
us their full backing
as a group we've been dialogue with
adrian avery from the council who's been
a great help we've now received a great
response from a recent survey that was
sent to local residents
using the results of the survey we are
now in a position to receive formal
quotations
from play equipment providers the
quotations receivable will then allow me
to enter
dialogue with charities businesses and
foundation as a local level as well as
national organizations to help to
request help with funding however one
stumbling block is that a number of
these organizations will not assist when
the project is on councilwoman land
over the last few years we've seen large
scale housing developments in the local
area it's my understanding that more
projects have been agreed it is also my
understanding that these projects are
supposed to inject funding into things
like bay area
i really do feel that the proposed
upgrade to the park would be an ideal
opportunity for the council to show the
benefits of these new housing
development developments being allowed
they'll even be described as being
situated in a low income area this is
why i feel is especially important to
have facilities for children that are
free to use increasing footfall at the
park will also benefit local shop owners
cafes also the boat and art gallery
a free-to-use amazing car would also be
great for tourist visiting and
encouraging repeat visits to the town
thank you for your time today i really
hope that the council will join and
fully support this initiative by all of
us working together i truly believe we
can provide a facility that the town
could be proud of
okay thank you mr thank you
all your comments will be taken on board
for sure
right our next speakers is tina wright
or alison bennett i don't know who wants
to
from the kitchen cupboard yes at the
valley market
that's right yes could you which one are
you there um
well when you said
you're lucky you've only got one of us
you have three minutes to address the
council when you're
ready i'm alison bennett um i'm a trader
in um great choice market um i just
wanted to talk briefly about the
renovation of the market building um
which i believe is up for discussion
this evening um
we just want i just wanted to um
emphasize really how important the
building is is the central feature of
the town
[Music]
the town council and
traders have been working really hard
since
covid to get the town back on its feet
and it's making real progress
but the
market the market building is in a quite
a strong state of repair at the moment
and unfortunately
and um
we just really wanted to um ask you to
really seriously consider um
financing the renovations that have been
planned um for some time now um i think
if it's put off too much longer then the
job in hand is going to be a much a much
more serious one to be done um
it frames the penny market which is
becoming such a vibrant place now for
people to visit
um but unfortunately it you know it's
the first thing you see when you're
coming into the pani market so um
it just needs to be to be brought up to
standard really
um and also houses the museum which
again has had a lot of work put into it
um
so
it's really just to ask you to give it
some serious consideration i know you've
got an awful lot to think about but um
i just wanted to say that thank you
thank you very much
our next public contribution is david
gibbons
chair of the trustees great torrential
museum
thank you
you also have three minutes next when
you settle
[Music]
well yeah thank you for giving me your
time to speak um as councillor said i am
the i'm dave gibbons i'm the chair of
trustees at towington museum
we relaunched in 2021 and we went
through times and town council the
market house above the pannier market as
a display space
i should say mid-advanced um
torridge has been very supportive over
the last year or so
with the work we've been doing on the
market on the market house
um
particularly i've got to give credit to
mike berryman for his help with the
issues around rainwater ingress coming
off the pannier market roof and down our
walls
right next to some electricity and some
brown side artifacts and it's been very
very good and very happy
however
and so i understand the penny market and
marketplace projects
was on the list of capital projects but
didn't meet the scoring thresholds for
the council
which struck me as a shame because all
the reports were done there was some
expensive research done planning
permission was granted so the project is
ready to go
i hesitate to use the phrase but you
could almost say he was up and ready
um one of the most important buildings
in the town centre is the market house
in the panhandle market both visually
and historically
its
condition as it stands and i hope most
of you are aware of what it looks like
at the minute and it really doesn't
reflect well on either the town or
and you can take it so i don't mean buy
it but
it also doesn't reflect particularly
well on the owners as guardians of this
very very important building
it is rapidly falling into disrepair
as an example
the bell tower which was on the top of
the
market house
if
uh
middle of last year if i hadn't warned
the council about the state of it
it wouldn't have been taken down and it
would almost certainly have landed in
the street over the last weekend i mean
i'm sure you've all seen the pictures of
south mountains um bell tower
so
that's really does speak to the state of
disrepair that the building is in that
the bell tower there was actually
rotting away and about to fall into the
street and obviously you can imagine the
costs and the living implications that
we go with that going on
so surely it's better to spend the money
now on the canyon market before it
degrades any further
the
hard work that the museum the volunteers
the trustees have
put in relaunching and i'd urge you all
to visit if you haven't already
and again the pannier market traders
genuinely isn't reflected in the
standard of
repair of the market house and the
pannier market
which to me is a pity
particularly if you relate that for
example to the excellent work being done
by chris fuller's team on the globe
hotel project
which connection to wind
which shares a lot of core heritage and
community values with the market
my last point really is that the
building is grade 2 stylistic which
means that according to historic
england's own words particularly
important buildings of more than special
interests
of which only 5.8 of all listed
buildings are two-star which is what
this one is
historic england's own guidance refers
to section 79 and 215 of buildings act
1984
which can be used where a building or
structure is by reason of its ruinous or
dilapidated tradition seriously
detrimental to the immunities of the
neighborhood
to legally enforce corrective works to
be carried out which i'm sure we don't
want to get to that point
so finally
thank you for your time and i would
employ you all to approve this project
with the greatest for that
thank you
thank you mr kittens thank you
we never get into debate or discussions
on the issues that are booked for about
amazon public at full council
but they are taken on board by officers
and relevant
lead members
so all the views regarding the park and
the
market house will be
fully considered
right we move on with the agenda item
three is
declarations of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
discussed
item four on the agenda is
to agree uh the agenda between parts one
and two there's currently no part two on
the agenda
item five on the agenda is to consider
correspondence
or other business especially brought
forward by
the direction of the one i only chair or
the chief exec
that's okay two victims nothing so
we'll move on then to item six which is
the start of the main meter the business
tonight
is the
medium term financial strategy
on pages four to twenty six of your
agenda
and our finance manager and section one
type one officer
david hayes will give us this
presentation
thank you
thank you councillors and apologies and
thanks for all those councils heard this
once or twice
um what will my presentation
cover i'll recap where the council was
this time last year and i'll do a brief
refresher on the sources of finance for
the council
i'll go through at some depth the
2022-23
well it says provisional is now final
settlement from central government
i'll talk about some non-settlement
related emerging financial pressures
i'll inform those of my key assumptions
of risk are in formulating the
medium-term financial strategy
i'll recap what that means for the
revenue budget
financial strategy and i'll cover the
recommendations and next steps and i'll
also answer any questions at the end of
the presentation that's part of this
talk
so where were we this time last year
well we were having some forecast
deficit for
2021-22
2022-23
2023-24 about 2024-25
and so we've projected the council of
those buddhists will come back into a
modest surplus and increasing by
2025-26
now council has a reserve called the um
transition and government funding
reserve which we use to balance the
budgets where the budgets are not
imbalanced that's another expression
which state is the
council's building society accounts and
essentially what we're saying is the
council's building society account would
have 8 000 pounds in it by the end of
2020
and i would say that this time last year
the total distribution council had an
endangered financial position compared
to a lot of councils of the demographic
for this country
where do we get our money from well we
obviously get it from council tax we get
it from retained business rights the
council retains fortune of the business
rates that it collects
fees and charges and central government
grants on the right hand side of the buy
truck departure you can see that the
amount money we have to get from central
government grant is in decline it has
been long term decline
and
season charges and increasingly
proportion of the funds and increasing
proportion of our expenditures
essentially we sometimes agree we stand
on our own two feet to somebody that's
right based on
now just remembers benefits and i'm sure
most of the ones here will be aware we
are the billing authority which if we
are made on the bill that goes out to 32
000 properties within torres district
council but we are collecting council
tax on behalf of our preceptors and the
past majority council tax that is
collected does not get retained by
torrey district council
up to 73 percent is retained by the
accounting
twelve percent by governor como police
four percent by the fire authority and
town and parish councils roughly three
percent i was sure that the council tax
bill has been in long-term decline and
i'm predicted to be about 8.34
for the 22-23 year
so to give some perspective
um the council tax for several
discussions which is restricted by
what's called council tax referendum
limits which are five pounds for a band
d equivalent property
um the impact of any increase that
tories would have on the council task
builder but ultimately these pay viruses
is fairly minimal and on the slide that
you can see behind me
and the left hand column shows all the
coins reflect how much the council tax
bills like to go up
and the contributing element to that
bill going up and as you can see by far
devon county's increase in the bill is
by far the largest component
followed by the police followed by
ourselves fire and the town crash
council so we have minimal impact on
actually the overall level of any
increase to the bills
whilst the impact of rises in total
share accountable tax liability to our
residents is limited the legacy for the
actual council of district council is
profound the chart below shows the
cumulative and annual income the council
is currently foregoing as a result of
previous decisions not to raise the
counter tax so the red line is the
cumulative amount of council tax we've
not collected because in previous years
we didn't increase the council tax and
the blue bar chart is the annual amount
that we're not collecting which we could
collect if we'd increased our council
tax back in 2010
11 2011 12 and i think 2012 13.
and those figures are 3.5 million pounds
is the queue
lost
which would basically replace four lower
recycling refuge vehicles when they're
next up for renewal
and the annual income with fargo is just
over four hundred thousand which
roughly equates to what our target is to
try and get the cost of leisure down to
about 2025 26 which is discussed late
uh i won't go into too much detail about
the business regular society to say that
as i said we've seen 40 percent of the
business rates
central government 50 percent dividend
county now percentage in sunset 510
whilst we collect the business rates we
don't set the business checks we don't
set the rates for value and we don't set
the charge in the power
as i alluded to the biggest single
component of income for the council is
fees and charges
and we collect just over six million
pounds from fees and charges from a wide
range of services some fees are step by
step such as planning fees
some fees we can only recover our costs
that are associated with them such as
land charges
and other fees of discretionary nature
the main discretion fees are listed on
the slide behind me and the top two
parking and garden waste and to a lesser
extent the federal rental the council's
commercial approaches they're by far the
biggest
potential for increasing income
so
keeps information which reminds me i
really should change my slide this is
the
2022-23 final settlement from central
government apologies
uh the headline figure government has
announced
publicizes 3.5 billion extra funding to
councils which is an increase of four
percent in real terms in the core
spending power
so it's important to members understand
what we mean by core spending power
television's core spending power
consists of our revenue support group
our rural services delivery we get extra
money because we're a rural authority
government recognizing customers want to
carry out certain services such as
refuge collection
and lower services to services grant and
a new grant called the service exam new
homes bonus which is um
[Music]
severely reduced of late council tax
income and retained business growth but
the important thing to note is when
government assesses our core spending
power they assume the council will
increase the council tax up to the
referendum the tories has five pounds
per band the equivalent and also they
make assumptions about the increase in
the growth of the council tax base of
the cash essentially the number of new
properties that come liable for council
tax
and central government in assessing
their funding without you will make
those assumptions
so how was the
final settlement for turrish
well the left-hand bar chart in blue on
the left-hand side 1.1
so we had an increase in our core
spending power 1.1
compared with other shire districts
across the uk that was
4.3
and that is less than inflation which in
november was 5.1 which actually is now
5.4 as of december
[Music]
the same and this slide is comparing us
to the southwest of england
and as you can see there we've had a one
point bombshell including our close
spending power the southwest on average
six point four percent
and
the other little final chart there we
are again on the left-hand side one
point one percent we're compared to our
deprivation groups councils summits some
of us in terms of the decoration within
the council area
and for our group and most likely
councils most matches
it's i think it's seven percent
this has taught me to change provisional
and also wear my glasses when doing the
presentation
so what have been the non-settlement
related pressures for the council we've
had emerging financial pressures
no surprises for most of the members say
that leisure has been the biggest
followed by staffing costs
followed by a vehicle replacement point
when you assign for our vehicle
replacement that will be covered later
by my colleague hudson when he goes
through the capital and also and there's
cost of residual tipping
so what's gone the other way what have
been the favorable movements for the
council's finances uh business rates
and the big movement in 25 2526 is an
assumption about additional business
rate income from renewable energy and
i'll come to that later
um planning income and i'll refer to
that later in the assumptions and risk
income from access to the northern
boroughs
and a vacancy target and i'll discuss
all these later
so on the financial pressures
by far the biggest pressure um for the
next financial year is leisure whereas
we reported into full council in
december 2021 measure reference biggest
revenue pressure to council region 10
financial strategy assumes that the cost
of providing leisure will fall to 450
000 pounds per annum by
2526. that income for leisure will
return to pre-pandemic levels in 2024-25
staffing
why we've got such crashes on staffing
well the first one is that the
government announced that there would be
a zero percent increase for the
financial year
2021-22 for the public sector now local
for example technically part of the
public sector and it'd only be staffed
on 24 000 and under who would get an
increase
well the actual latest pay offer from
the local association is 1.75 so we've
got a question that we under budgeted
for the staffing increases
as you may be aware we're all personally
anybody who pays national insurance from
the 1st of april we'll all be paying
more cash insurance as individuals but
total digital cash will also be paying
more national insurance
as an employer in order to contribute to
an increased adult social care
expenditure
and we're also from our actress we've
been informed that it's likely that our
employer pension contributions will rise
from 2023-24
and also we've made some tweaks to the
assumptions about future pay awards
vehicles i don't want to take
peter hudson's thunder away from his
capital presentation but essentially in
order to fully fund the replacement of
our refuge fleet we need to put more
money aside on an annual basis
typically we went out to a
tender exercise and what happened the
cost came back for tipping off their
waste that's at the deepmore facility in
titan
so i did allude that not everything was
a bad news story
planning the financial years 2020 21 22
the planning had just been
unprecedented we've basically received
the budget over 100 above budget
and i've made an assumption that mtfs
that uh planning will be 250 000 a year
above budget for the remainder of their
medium-term financial strategy northern
boroughs we extended the access period
the season essentially for access of
vehicle access to the northern boroughs
and we're focused on that we'll make an
upload to our would be a favorable
movement on the budget so 125 000.
i
made the decision to increase the
vacancy target of five hundred thousand
that's not actually a good news though
that reflects the difficulties this
council has experienced in recruiting
staff so posts are basically remaining
empty
longer uh frontline staff we don't have
a vacancy target so people in the refuge
park with a driver um leads or is off
sick we get agency staffing um clinical
staff tend not to be a direct
replacement we have to actively go out
and prove to the person who's left
and on business rates and forecasting
increased income but primarily important
increase
[Music]
in renewable energy and when the council
by planning authorizes a renewable
energy scheme the council keeps 100
percent of the business rates
okay i think everybody here in this room
today will be aware that inflation is a
big news story
um
the council doesn't operate in and
operates in the same environment what we
all do in our own personal lives the
charter shows that what the inflation is
coming from used gas on the left-hand
side and electricity
at construction price inflation
um salary inflation general inflation
and what i'm trying to show from that
chart is that general inflation is 5.5.4
[Music]
increasing our council tax up to the
maximum we're allowed by referendum
limits to 2.9 percent is still
significantly below the audition rise
and just to give some context so some of
our contracts with gasoline electricity
i think are up for renewal in october of
2022. potentially we'll have some
increased cost gas and electric
so what about my key assumptions
i assume the council tax will rise by
the referendum limit for the duration of
the meeting to financial strategy
i've assumed that leisure income will
return to pre-pandemic levels by 24-25
and the cost of providing leisure
services to the council will be circa
450 000 pounds per annum by 25.26
i've also assumed the pay award for
council staff will be two percent random
over the life of the median sale
financial strategy which the completion
being as it is today may be a bit of a
stretch
and i've assumed that employer pension
contribution will rise by 1.25
from 233 24
the medians and financial strategy makes
no assumptions about future government
review of local quality funding what
used to be called the fair funding
review made no assumptions about that
the median term financial assumes
additional income from planning
and building and planning and northern
boroughs are 250 and 120 000 pounds
respectable
so i just want to give some context the
risk of assumptions i'm including the
meet and sad financial track the chart
behind me
i'm going to say i think it might call
color blindness these four
bar charts which are roughly about five
hundred six hundred thousand pounds a
year which are in aqua
they're the that's the planning income
that we had for the financial years 1617
to 1920
the ones in the dark blue at the
previous financial year and what we're
forecasting for the current financial
year
the chart in yellow is what i've put in
the budget for the median financial
strategy
who knows if i'm correct
the last two years have not reflected
what's gone before us
so i also want to show the risks
associated so what would be the impact
if the council decided not to increase
the council tax for this financially
then financially in 2022-23
the bar charts in aqua
i'll agree show the deficit
and the ones in red show the deficit
should we not increase the council tax
in 2020 to 23. as you can see
the budgets never come into balance if
we don't increase the council tax
and also the transition of government
funding reserve the building society
account i referred to earlier we
actually got overdrawn on them so we
don't actually have the resources in the
transition government fundraiser to
balance our books and we're legally
advised to balance our books
so
why are they doing
been accused by sean of sucking the
energy out of the room
and not being a lost public scheme
um so
one needs to remind you what i've been
the two biggest contributing factors to
our surpluses in the last this last
20 21 and the year to the moment well
there's been two contributing factors
but simply we've had more funding from
government in support of our coalit
measures than the additional cost and
loss income that we've incurred so the
central government has given us grant
funding relating to clovid more than our
costs
and planning income as i showed
previously has shown unprecedented
levels of income
i'm hoping that the pandemic is coming
towards them and there will be no
additional cold refunded in the
financial year 2012 police proved and
i'm certainly not projecting to getting
caught with funding i've already
budgeted
for 250 000 extra planning income for
2022-23
[Music]
so what does it all mean
about two slides ago i gave you a little
bit of a preview of this so in blue
is where sorry apologies
in red is where we were this time last
year so we were just coming back into
surplus and 24-25 and a little bit more
in 25 26
and now i'm saying that we stay in
deficit
for up to 25 26 and we basically break
even
in 26 27. however that's with all those
caveats i've said all those unknowns
higher worlds mean two percent etc
inflation
and what's the impact on the transition
in government funding reserve
well to question the chase we're going
to use 1.4 million of our transition
government fund i'll build a decide to
count
to balance the books over the next four
years
based on my assumptions
so i'm just just somewhat a small
graphic so here we have a seesaw and
hopefully it's in balance our income on
one side business rates granting council
tax fees and charges
is balanced by the statutory services we
have to provide and the non-statutory
services that we choose to
fund if
income goes down we don't increase the
council tax so we have a bad settlement
for government
the
balance of the councils
it's nothing bouncing but the seesaw
is going down on the right-hand side
and if we can't raise additional income
the only way that we can bring the
seesaw back into balance is to reduce
our non-statutory expenditure
so i'm just trying to get the visual
button
slides have gone through it's really
trying to get us into this balanced
position
so there are recommendations
so the recommendation is our band the
council time for 2022 is increased by
five pound which is the referendum which
is equal to 2.9 percent of 173 pounds 86
to 178 pounds 66
the net revenue budget 2022-23
is and in the report it says 7.983 that
actually should read
7.609 million because the figure the
higher figure was before the utilization
of the transition government funded
reserve to balance the books
and the contributions to reserve are as
outlined in paragraph 11.4 and 11.5
which is used for transitioning
government from the reserve to balance
now it's also for members to note the
robustness or otherwise of the budget
that presented to you
might be assumptions and forecasts that
i've applied in developing immediate
financial stress and the risks that i've
had to identify i think at this juncture
i'll pass over to the leader of the
council hudson you want to say a few
words
thank you how can i follow that
he says he sucks the energy out of the
room
i think that's a misnomer david
i've never known financial facts
presented in a way that i actually
understand what's going on the clarity
and insight that you give and share with
us all i think is of the highest
standard so i finished sucking up to you
uh just do a good job and carry on
balancing our books
i think some of the challenges that we
have faced
uh have been extreme
the issue of our settlement as you know
we have raised with our mp um as to why
our settlement has been so low and we
will continue to pursue that
however we need to
agree with these recommendations tonight
and we need to go forward with
some of the
uh assumptions
that our section one card one officer
has had to make
but he's not alone all section 151
officers will be speculating in certain
areas but i trust his judgment
so tonight i would like to recommend to
you that we accept
a b c and d
in our recommendations
and that we note
that the chief finance officer
section 151 officers assurance of the
robustness of the budget set out in
section 13 in report
though the assumptions and forecasts
apply to develop the
outlined in section 8
and note the risks associated with the
budget 2223
and the median term financial service
no not service
strategy outlined in section 12.
so i would like to move those and i call
for a second with a motion
capture
that was the fourth one is that part of
the
it is part of the recommendation
my apologies council
again
d on the recommendation is that a
working group
to be established the membership to be
agreed by full council
to be tasked with reporting back to
community resources for options to bring
the council's finances back into balance
so that's
the future but that's part of the
recommendation and members will note
that this has been
to community resources and they're
overviewing scrutiny internal
so it's been moved
and seconded that we accept
this
resolution
can
countrybrand
um
in terms of the settlement central
government i know
you've heard more words about how we're
going to pursue that
but in all honesty is there any
possibility that we will get any
supplementary income from central
government because the trouble is you
group is denied a balance of books or
will
go down this line anyhow and they're
just going to turn around and laugh like
they have already i mean i can't see
that our part-time empty there's going
to be any good at all in trying to
forward our case other ones who would
have done it by now clearly haven't
you i'm brand new london if you want to
have
going back to what you're originally
saying david back back in the um
when we did not uh increase the budget
at the time of austerity in the
coalition government i mean that was
because members felt really angry that
that we were actually being asked to uh
increase council tax stealth tax after
all
in order to bail out central government
which didn't work in any case
so just for clarity this is a final
settlement another left provisional
throughout the presentation which is my
mistake but that settlement is final
right thank you it's been proposed and
seconded to accept those this resolution
sandra could you take a recording vote
please
thank you chair
councillor banter for
councillor brenton or councillor bright
uh councillor clark or
penceler cottle
or pencilla craigy or
pencil agave or tencella hackett or
pencilla haines or tencella harding or
pencilla hawkins or chancellor heppell
or chancellor hex or chancellor hodgson
or councillor haley or
cancer inch or
counselor james or counselor jones or
langford or councillor laws or
councillor leather tor councillor lock
for councillor manly or councillor
mackenzie
or
councillor newton or councillor
pennington
or councillor watson or councillor
wiseman or
councillor woodhouse
that's unanimous chair
thank you
thank you i'll move on now to i i told
seven on the agenda
and uh
david's got to stay where he is because
on pages 27-32
is the council tax resolution for 22-23
[Music]
[Music]
there was a legal obligation for thomas
council to approve the council tax
resolution in its capacity as a building
authority
so our partners in the county council
government the cornwall fire and police
development so
democracy set back now various town and
paris councils have informed us of their
research
they report you having to show the
impact of that on the council tax across
tourist district council so just for
information devon county council
increased their preset by 2.99 percent
government cornwall police increased
theirs by 10 pound per van d which
equated to 4.36 percent government
somerset far increased there by 1.99
and the various town parish councils on
average increase their charges by 5.28
so that means that average vandy
property in torridge is
214.91 pounds of which torridge's share
will
[Music]
thank you david
well i'll move the recommendation from
the chairs at the top of page five there
the council approve the formal tax
council resolution the 2223 has set out
in appendix one to this report
thank you
can we call you the books on the please
again a recording
thank you chair
council about
councillor brenton
councillor bright
chancellor clark or councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor craigie or penceler gov
or chancellor hackett or councillor
haynes or
chancellor hardy or councillor hawkins
or councillor happle or councillor hex
or councillor hudson or councillor
harley or
councillor inch or
councillor james or councillor jones or
councillor langford or councillor laws
or councillor leather or
councillor locke or councillor manley or
councillor mckenzie
or
councillor newton four councillor
pennington or councillor watson or
councillor wiseman
councillor woodhouse
that's unanimous chair thank you
okay thank you thank you david for
presenting that thing wishing soon have
to do with you up in london
okay we move on then item eight on the
agenda
is the capital program 22 23
to 26 27 not just that's on pages 33 to
41
of your report and our deputy section
151 officer pete hudson will take this
one thank you thank you jen good evening
everyone
so i'm just going to take you through
the capsule program um
and this is to be updated for the next
um five years so we're going to start by
updating the forecast spending and risk
receipts
and then move on to inflation in both
the vehicle program and
building cost and tender price
we'll then look at the new
[Music]
so we'll move on to the new pins
which have been submitted and then
the
transform
coming from the future for leisure and
also vehicles when we're moving to
electric
um from this we'll get the update of the
gap from the shortfall
and then we look at this both in the
vehicle program long term and also
general pressures on the general future
pressures on the general program moving
forwards
so
this first slide is um where we started
off and started where the current budget
is so we had a 24 million pound capital
budget program um which is roughly
balanced giving us 142 000 pound surplus
so from this we've updated the funneling
which is additional receipts and
from things such as right to buy
and any
any asset sales and we've also then got
forecast adjustments to revenue
contributions this is
for adjustments to the new homes bonus
et cetera just so over 2 million and
we've then updated for the dfg which is
disabled
facilities grant spending
and extended the overall program by a
year all this together moves the program
forward and this actually gives rise to
a 2.6 million pound surplus
at this point
we then move to update the program for
inflation and the vehicle program
sorry so this adds a roughly 600 000
pound of inflation and we also need to
extend the vehicle program out for the
full foot for five years
and this reduces the surface slightly so
we end up with
about a 2.3 million pounds surface at
this point
so from there we look at the inflation
impacts which is on in our building
building costs really so this is from
the royal institute of giant surveyors
um
[Music]
these figures come from october and
they're probably moving forward slightly
from them
but basically we're seeing pressures of
16.9 percent of materials
and also general building costs are
rising at nine percent for the year and
looking at their forecasts for the next
five years and though this is reducing
it's still um
increased inflationary pressures
so from there we've reviewed what are
the projects in our current program and
which ones are affected by that
um so
we identified 12 project areas which
equate to roughly 10 million pounds
worth of project costs and this includes
the
environmental center which is seven
million pounds of that so we apply a
approximate 10 of inflation this adds
977 000 pounds worth of additional costs
so then the table below is updating the
program for that and that reduces the
surplus the forecaster plus to 1.3
million
then we move on to the
new pits so this is a list of the new
kids that have been proposed by officers
so
we've got win win more lane
refurbishment we've got the digitization
of the revenue and benefits service
we've got disabled access pathways
outside capstone
we've got ground maintenance equipment
we've got core server we've got the
torrent companion market
sandimir road um improvements and
electric vans for the maintenance team
and electric advancement car parks
they've got victoria park play area and
the fish truck ice machine
i should say that grounds maintenance
equipment was approved by fall council
back in december and the fish stock ice
machine
were moved in january
so we were to include all these bits
this actually reduces uh the forecast
surplus
um to just about 1000.
however at this point we've still got
some
other quite significant pressures so
we've got the leisure pro leisure's
quite a big obviously um pressure at the
moment
they're coming back to a local authority
trading company
so
there's an initial assessment which
indicated around
thousand pounds of capital maintenance
required and also an additional 60 000
per year the site is estimated for the
three leisure centres this adds up to
about 900 000 pounds over the five year
life of the program
now we've got some money set aside from
um last year in the reserve which
reduces the
pressure on the program
we've also then we've got vehicle
electric vehicle updates so this is just
this is a forecast of the pressure that
we think the program will be under over
the future
um so we've already got two bids
proposed for additional costs
but this is um trying to estimate an
additional cost for the over 24 vans
this is just the small vans not the
refuse laurens as there's not currently
a
solution for those
um so we add the leisure in the vehicles
electric vehicle pressures onto the
program we actually end up with our
surplus turning to a short form so we're
actually 300 000 pounds short
right
so then this shortfall really should be
sort of device
should really be looked at as the
general program and the vehicle and the
larger vehicle program so about half of
the shortfall relations vehicle program
and about half the shortfall to the
general
capital program
so we take the vehicle program first
and the vehicle program consists of
approximately 30 large
refuse recycling sweeper lorries and
around 27 small and medium bands
now we have an annual
um
so we compare the cost versus what we
currently bring to the revenue program
we've got a
current cost of replacement for this
fleet of about 4.7 million pounds and an
average life of about seven years
now that works at
an annual cost of 675 000 and we're
currently putting in 555 000 so you can
see there's a little bit of a gap there
now
the reason for that gap as we can see in
this chart is that the current um for
the replacement of the current fleet
um we started off with some general
reserves and we also put the sale of the
depots in there so the program is
balanced obviously the large fleet
replacement which comes in at 26.27
um but from then on it we don't increase
the revenue contributions by the time we
get to the following fees replacement in
32 33 we have a shortfall of 3.2 million
therefore um to sort of
to tackle this um
this shortfall if we increase the
the contributions from revenue to
uh by a hundred thousand six hundred and
fifty five thousand and then increase
them by approximately five percent for
inflation then we end up with a program
which is roughly balanced for the long
term
so that that's how we would balance the
vehicle program for the long term um so
now we've turned back to the general
program um and this is
so the other part of the shortfall which
is about 177 000 at this point
however
this
doesn't include all the future pressures
that we've got um coming over the life
of the next five years really so what i
mean by that is although we've got pids4
2223 submitted we've got no bids for
um for four years following that so
if we if we take a rough estimate of 500
000 pounds a year for bids
um that would equate to an additional
two million pounds that we're sure
we also have a pressure on the horizon
from the defences of westwood home
which is a large project which we'll be
working in conjunction with the
environment agency
um it's still a way off but initial
estimates would expect it to be around
the three million amount and
tend to require sort of a significant
contribution from turret possibly up to
50 or 1.5 million
um we then got removed to electric
hybrid refuse vehicles
which at the moment don't meet the needs
of a
rural hilly
district that we are
um
but when they do i think the cost of
they're going to be significant
additional costs
and lastly we've got desktop strategy
which is our current license is run to
2024 and that's where they'll need
another further refresh and that's
estimated to be around 250 000. so we're
adding that together that's about
303.75 million
sorry
of additional pressures
so
so just to surprise our current
shortfall of 177 000 but with future
pressures of approaching four million
and we then actually
this assumes that so the current
shortfall is assuming that all the bits
are recommended by full council
so each of the bids um needs to be
approved by full council to be included
in the program
now each kid
in the blog the table on the next slide
basically has a project score and a
financial score now the projects has
been scored by the leader the chief exec
in the section 151 all out
and in the
um
process which was
which in the last year has been
redeveloped
and approved by um
internal ons and there is actually a
quality bar recommendation where we
recommend a
minimum project score of about 65 000.
65 out of 100
and we also have a financial school
which is just to allow pro uh projects
to be compared with each other to see
what um the cost pressure is on on the
council these point representatives
representing a hundred thousand pounds
worth of costs
so here here we have the list of the
bids um which have been and their
corresponding scores
so we've got the
core server
capstone disabled access paths um
reps and venice bit
redstone benefit digitization and
sanding around
and there are there are two pits for
sundermere road
they're in either all
and then below the line we've got the
torum timpani market um electric bands
and victoria park play area
and window
um so just to summarize our
our current shortfall of 177 000 with
all the bits but actually with the
recommendations on the next page this
actually changes to a surplus in the
current year of 460 000
um but the graph is just to show that
well that's a small surplus with the
future pressures we've actually got
quite a significant shortfall
at the end of the five-year program
so just just to wrap up um
i'm sorry just to wrap up that um our
current short form of 177
and with a surplus um
also the future pressures to consider
so move to the recommendations which is
that members consider that the
recommendations by both community and
resources
and internal overview and scrutiny and
to full council that the capital program
is updated for the building cost
inflation
the vehicle program is updated for
inflation and the vehicle program is
balanced in the long term by increasing
the contributions from revenue
and the pins that meet the minimum
recommendation recommended project score
of 65 are included in the capital
programme
these consist of the core server cuts
down access pathways reps and benefits
and the sanding sunday mirror
and just to note that
kids which fall below this score um
are can be referred back to officers
further work refinement and possible
future construction
thank you very much
thank you pete thank you for that
detail
uh presentation
council mckenzie
um
he did say that although it was over 65
would result in a surplus of 200 000 but
there's two for san diego i'm assuming
you've er
that's the lower figure yeah yes that's
correct
thank you
councillor laws
uh thank you chair um i'm a little
concerned over the linear defense
um
it seems
that
central government aren't bearing the
brunt of this i mean
we're vulnerable we happen to be a
district council
facing the waters
but it seems grossly unfair and it's
like well we hope that there are only
one up top
that would just
decimate our
future spending on other other projects
is that the case
are we sure that the central government
do not bear
a
bigger responsibility
[Music]
um thank you thanks council of laws um
as you said as you say we don't we're
not sure at this stage obviously we'll
be pressing uh for a bigger share of
resource from the environment agency i
know councillor hudson is working with
the local government association special
interest group
and i don't know can talk to whether you
want to add anything but obviously these
are early estimates at the moment the
officer team are working with the
environment agency to develop the scheme
so at this stage uh the whole costs are
not established and equally we will be
trying to get as much funding towards it
as is possible but again
um that's a lobbying group to try and
attract more funding but i just come
back and just say that
this scheme is not cloud critical and
miles away uh the one of the chief
officers of the environmental agency
witnessed storms last winter and
immediately
up the
list because 73 households are at risk
and uh
we're told at that time we were looking
possibly two years that was the year ago
to commence work so
it just came it just concerned me as a
district council
right thank you council laws council
hodgson
thank you um chief exec for passing the
bat on to me
um
the the issue for us is that uh we do
work closely with the environment agency
with regard to
where we are being prioritized compared
to all our
uh neighbours far flung from the
north coast down to
the isle of wight
all competing for environment agency
funding for vulnerable coastlines
now it will depend on where we are
assessed and we can make the
representations as a local authority
to
um government and through the
environment agency for additional
funding
and it is at the moment um in i say in
their hands we need to lobby we need to
make sure we're aware of what our
financial situation is and what we can
contribute because everybody is happy in
hand to the environment agency because
we are not alone
as a local authority in meeting the
challenges of
our budget constraints so um
yes we will continue to raise this and
yes it is an area of concern
but as i said before we're not ignoring
it we are taking it to the appropriate
agencies and having those discussions
uh on that note
i think again we've got a very
rounded report here
uh we have the opportunity
to reconsider some of the pins that
people have spoken to
tonight
um in the public consultations
making representations we have the
opportunity to reconsider or look at
those again
but as it stands i would like to move
the recommendations of this report
for approval
thank you councillor hudson cashing
newton and i will second that thank you
councillor cottle honking
they could have sent that letter in or
said
we've
we've never had the recommendation
that's on page 40 moved and
um
and really i'd rather go to the votes on
that
i think we're very well aware from what
was said earlier on about the issues
with
with torrington and as the deputy
leaders just said they're not going to
be ignored at all laws they will be
considered as will the park in victoria
park indeed
but at this point
at this point
um
we have to go to the votes on what's in
front of us now what's been recommended
by community resources and that will be
in scripture
[Music]
[Music]
chief execs
we've been informed apparently that
this might be the way forward for you to
read out
from the torrington mayor
yes she
wrote email democratic services
um telling them that she would feel
i mean personally i'd rather that people
always email the rest of the counselors
around with things like that will you
carry on
um so this is from councillor keeley
allen great
town councillor and deputy mayor of
greater enfield dear members of toronto
district council i'm writing to express
my eagerness to see more funding and
work aimed towards the canyon market in
great terrain
under the capital project funding as
you'll be aware town centres are working
extremely hard to rebuild themselves
after the hard times during coving and
we in great torrents uncertainly are not
restful on our laurels there is such an
incredible fuzz about the town and i
believe that is due to the huge amounts
of hard work that is going in making
sure we bounce back and become even
stronger than ever
our shop holders have been nothing short
of amazing during the last two years and
i've stood up and met the needs of the
people in great torington this also
applies to our independent children
who have been working hard and creating
good working relationships with each
other in order to make sure theirs and
everyone else's business is bright
unfortunately the disappointing state of
the pania market is very much letting
them all down
our hannah market should be one of the
crowning jewels in the town it sits
proudly overlooking the town square but
it appears to sit very sadly at present
the frontage has needed extensive work
for a long time now and the two front
shops especially have to deal with their
names
and we heard from um allison chief and
friend of those shots that he's talking
about
whilst they understand that such plans
do take time i think now is the time to
act and support our traders and our
community porridge district council has
a right to make sure its buildings are
being kept highly unpresentable and i
believe the planning market has been
waiting long enough now
from my understanding the planning
market was a fact project a few years
ago and some drainage and some small
cosmetic works were completed these
works were very much welcomed after the
cafe and shops i've dealt with floods
from the drains for many years i am
however unsure what other works should
have been completed under this capital
project and would be very interested to
know how much was spent
to conclude i would urge and encourage
you all to consider the canadian market
and the capital project this year i
would like to see the following included
in the project renovation of the
frontage of the pannier market any
cosmetic works inside the pentagon and
works for the market house i look
forward to hearing the outcome of the
meeting find the guards
keely allen
thank you i'd just like to ask that um
we are a local planning authority so we
should be setting an example
and also as uh dave gibbons mentioned
earlier we also need to meet the legal
requirement from historic england as it
is a grade two-star list of buildings it
needs to be up to a certain standard so
i don't understand we own the market
house we've got it there it's all
everything's gone in um the planning all
the reports have been made which
presumably costs the council of
thousands of pounds already it's all
ready to go
why are we going to wait for it to get
worse and presumably
even more money when we should just be
getting on and doing it now need to be
done at some point
so
i recommend that we just get on and do
it now
definitely thank you councillor cottle
hankin
council landfill thank you
i just wanted to say as well as
supporting that i just wanted to say
about victoria park
i think councillors need to be aware
that the play strategy said that we
agreed and with money was spent on the
play strategy center victoria park won't
be finished this year but work would
start on victoria park this year i do
not see i do not think
that if um victoria park isn't included
here i do not see that any work is going
to start in victoria park this year and
i think it needs to and if it doesn't
then the play strategy that we all
agreed
fails at the first hurdle really that's
my opinion thank you
[Music]
thank you council
councillor craigie
i'd like to suggest an amendment to the
motion that we drop the cats down past
and put in the victorian part instead
thank you
well they
have a completely different project
so if i can just speak of a as a member
of the working group who together with
uh peter
revives the
um scoring system for the pigs
and the reason we were asked and
required to do that
as part of the ons internal
committee
was
in order to improve
the quality and robustness of the
projects that we
uh approve
this isn't the prioritization
of the actual
subject this is actually the quality of
the technical project that's going to
deliver that uh particular
item and that is why we lifted the bar
uh in in the scoring system uh in order
to make sure that we as counselors can
be confident that
projects which go forward
are being done to the correct standard
and represent the correct value for
money for taxpayers
and we we all know examples we've had in
the past where we've perhaps fallen
short in that area and that is why
we
rewrote or revised the scoring system
and
councillor kotlinkin i think you were
part of that committee who who voted for
that new system
um
what then comes out of the comes out of
that scoring
one has to accept
um because
that that's that's we set it up to
achieve that
and various things haven't actually
met the the grade well this has been
said there is the opportunity for them
to go back to officers to see if the
quality and robustness of the actual
project being put forward can be
improved so that therefore it can
actually get above the line but
basically if we take something that's
below the line now
we're actually saying that technically
it was inferior it didn't make the
standard reset
and so it's like getting a tender which
is not up to it but you say oh well i'll
go for it because i want it well
we must be patient and go back and say
no we want to see a higher technical
standard and then we'll be able to
approve it
these items are not competing against
each other there was no spot of money
these items are all taken on their own
so uh i believe that we should we should
take it as it is
cancer brenton
thank you jeremy
is on page 38
1.8 it says each of the proposed bids
will need to be approved by full council
before it's included in the capital
program so we're here to debate this on
and then
you look at the uh
the pits and follow the recommendation
on page 40
d
which is what we presume you're going to
do
for uh approval by council
i would uh
uh
amendment
that c
200 and c 204
namely the cancer disabled access
pathways and
the sandomir road be deleted
so that would release up money then
the more
urgent ones namely
torrington
uh market and the equipment with
victoria
let's let's deal with the ones i
recommend that should be deleted
sounded amir wrote that that was not
done that many years ago it doesn't work
whoever designed it needs to be taken
shot really it just doesn't work you go
down there in the summer when it's busy
i mentioned this before it's you know
so it's busy people do not usually drive
you know
you could spend a fortune out there
trying to rectify that and we don't have
a fortune so we just have to sit on one
side
people will make the best of it as they
can at the moment
in terms of disabled access
come on
we've got four disabled places out here
why do we need two down there with a
zigzag path if you're a disabled person
or you've got your carer pushing them up
as an exact path
it's paved in gold it's still ain't
going to work very well to get them up
to the front of this building it doesn't
that does not need doing i've discussed
it with the chair of council last last
meeting here we couldn't see for the
likeness why that's been glued
so this would release up some money
which would be a bit of um
incentive to get these other two done
both of which by the way can be done
through some form of partnership
we know victoria park have have money
promised to them or at least the player
is impoverished from both the town
council and the british trust
so there's a partnership we're going to
challenge these figures about how much
it's going to cost and it doesn't have
to be all done overnight
in terms of
turning company market likewise there's
no reason why there should not be some
partnership with torrington town council
as
as well as
covering our legal obligation to the
building as council of christie's
pointed out capacitor river took over
its um our market and you know i know we
pay the princely sun to torridge
rental you know around a year
so that um you know not losing any money
um but nonetheless
and we did
did not have a vast amount of money from
tourists in order to do so well you
remember you want to counter the time i
think
so it can be done we can do these things
and they are urgent and they do need
doing those those two items
because the park in particular is part
of the sort of honeypot if you like that
draws people into biddeford
we've got a lovely skateboard park and
they're brilliant
and we victoria park i mean i've lived
in northern all while
and i see people and i live
i've seen people in biddeford
who have come from that side of the
river they come over here this is the
best victoria park's the best play area
in north dakota notre water
and they bring their kids over here and
they're going to come into the town also
got a skate party as well you know it is
an attraction and we should utilize it
and not meditate
you you know as well as i do in the past
there have been attempts to shut up or
at least shut the facilities you know
when it has glasses are pulled all right
shut it down close it down properly over
like it did impossible with layers
so i urge you as i say this is an event
that we um delete those two items so
that money can be switched over to one
more one
second yeah
right
that's an amendment but yeah
i've just remind members that it does
say that these kids that have failed the
scoring process and we've all been or
many of us have been to the pit meetings
where all these have been considered and
mowed over time and again seeing our
overlooked them all and the same
arguments have been made at cnr as have
been made tonight about those
our internal overall scrutiny have
looked at it and again
they've molded it over they've listened
to the arguments for them
and if you were to delete those two and
that's a repair work on salami road and
what i would consider and if we
discussed all these carefully the
disabled access pathways people got to
come up there and it's not just disabled
people people going to come up those old
either weddings or births
registered or deaths
and it's not
you take those to it you're looking at
92 000 and you mentioned the two schemes
the park and torrington that's 176
and 173 together but nowhere near being
able to afford either of those but
they're not being just discounted and
left to one side but i'll bring them
shrouding i think because like sean can
explain better but you know we've really
carefully those who've been involved
looked at these
yes exactly joe thank you uh just just
on the capstone
i think it's important the members
understand what we have here and it does
i think on the basis it doesn't look
like an overall provision of parking but
you've got in this building 13 serviced
offices these facilities the registrar
and lots of other units around the side
the parking that runs up the side here
is all allocated to the units and the
offices so it's not public parking
over there you've got 12 public parking
spaces there are a hundred capacity in
this building nowhere near service
so underneath is where people park to
come here at the moment it's not
compliant
it's it's what it basically needs doing
so we don't have adequate disabled
parties so that's just a justification
thank you sean
with
council council craig
if i could just point out that on the
victorian farm it wouldn't just be
funded by this council we said i don't i
remember a year ago
and said you don't have a budget for the
um play equipment we won't have any
player equipment and here we are saying
it again we have a play strategy we've
all agreed that we know that
during one part has got to be done we
know that bit of return council's put 25
000 in we know that the british trust
has put 25 000 in we know that we've got
the money for dermott's um disabled
swing
and we've had them now for about five
years so really this is getting a little
bit tedious and if the case for that
project was not sufficiently made by the
officers and the program hadn't been put
together submissively well and that's
happened to the council that burns the
offices and i just can't see how you
prioritize i don't know i don't
understand the kids program and i don't
think you're looking at the fact that we
are a tourist attraction
and we get our money from tourism and
people
come to benford because we've got lovely
parks and we've got the new facility
every time some play equipment breaks
it's not mended it's taken away even if
the press
the rubber footprint at the bottom
it is destroyed
then their play equipment is taken away
because of health and safety it's not
replaced
it's absolutely ridiculous and we had to
get a grip on it
we've been doing this for three years
now on this council but please
can we get this sorted
thank you councillor i think
and then we've got two amendments to
vote on first i just like to agree with
what everything out there never said
these pits have been scrutinized and
scored by
um officers and approved by cnr
and ons and i fear that if we start
changing them around at this stage it
would affect our budget
and i just don't think at this late
stage right but every sympathy with
victoria park and toronto market they
won't be started they can be
reconsidered and i just think fiddling
around now or not feeling is the wrong
word changing the strategy now is too
late and we should stick with what we've
got
right thank you bob i'll ask um
[Music]
to six thousand which i gather is based
on an estimate it's not all
real quotes um it's just i don't know it
just seems that we should be putting
money into positive creative programs
i
[Music]
[Music]
thousands of pounds were spent on it
only a few years ago and now we're
talking about advocating precious
funding towards more work
and what i just wanted to clarify you
say the ones that come under 65 percent
couldn't be representable
maybe shortly clarify how they're
revisited
i mean would it be in terms of like
funding coming available or something
and if that's the case would it come
back to the school council for
cnr or something for further
consideration i mean honestly on my
climbing thing i'm still very concerned
about the electric bands because we've
got a two character target
i want to reach that part of that zero
target
i have that concern about that as well
as sharing with certain developments
thank you sorry about it i'm just sorry
just to talk about one of the issues
well the pathways here at castdown is
our insurance
you know we do have a liability for
insurance one of the things is that we
kind of
have an inspection regime in our parts
of the pathways are
in good order and if we found that we've
just let them go to the wrapping room to
be simple
that would affect our insurance premiums
sometimes it's
it's not he said an added value or
something kind of under expression use
campaign sometimes
just keeping things
in a decent condition is a neta
requirement
but use all these things
responder and then
he'll read out there's two amendments
now being put forward but first of all
chief integral expert uh thanks cher so
i'm gonna respond to a council game's
question about uh what happens when
these kids can
remove again as has been alluded to so
um if you think about victoria park for
example to start and start with so there
has been some funding
from british trust and midfield town
council i think if we look back a couple
of years ago when we were talking about
the the park in toronto and councillor
cop hunting was very successful in
attracting uh community funding and
fundraising so there's opportunities
around that and obviously uh parts of
the
leveling up agenda and government grants
uh allude to leisure and social activity
so there may be opportunities for uh
further grants now further grants
honesty helped the scoring because as
you get more income to a project it
enhances the scoring
so on the on the torrent pannier market
um it's been mentioned by a couple of
pencillers who i don't wait
it um i like biddeford honey market uh
that's managed by the time council so
again it's a conversation we could have
with torrington town council and the
leader and i have a meeting with the
mayor and town clerk this friday and if
members recall members were at cnr we
said we would meet with the term
mayor and the clerk to discuss whether
the town council would be willing to
take the
the
property over
longer term and that then again might
help facilitate a better scoring
mechanism so there are some
opportunities to look at um and bring
these projects back into the latest
stage
thank
[Music]
can the officers look really urgently at
the penny market
it's ridiculous
it should be the jewel in the crown of
that square
we're letting join we've got to be aware
as a council we're perceived to be
letting them down
i'm sure if officers look really
urgently
we have to move this year
next year again
this year
on those items
just look urgently i think it's the wish
of this council
because i
i want
well i have to support the system
absolutely newton's explain exactly why
we all knew that it's not that the
system's floored but we have an urgent
need
thank you jen
cottle honking i'll let you have this
last sale of it and then we must get
this book
my concern is at the very end it says
with the pits that fall below this will
be referred back to officers for further
work or requirement which is fine but
then it says possible
future consideration it's the possible
part
partners
definitely come back to school council
with more information
further consideration within the next
three months
came
we introduced a scoring system or
internal scrutiny here they've done a
lot of work on it with the finance
officers with themselves to come up with
a system to stop what always happens
with these things we always have the
meetings we always discuss them we
always come to a conclusion and then
when it comes to actually making the
root decision we all start arguing about
it again
yeah we can't do it
why is the first time
a system we've actually bring some
sanity into
well i haven't been on the couch for a
long time there's been quite some silly
discussions
[Music]
which was to score to come up to 65
and on some of them it didn't
i'm sorry
that is the system that was introduced
this is the first year we're using it
and already you're saying well we'll
just take this out and we just add this
up sorry
this is the council you introduced a
system
on the majority it's been through cnr
springfield internally what's up every
single thing with all of them
i would have been quite happy to mark
them all 65 to start with but we can't
do that we have to do with what was said
as in terms of reference
the only sensible thing is it's what
you've heard tonight from some quarters
we approve what's on the board
and then future looking at what could be
done on some of those other pages and we
can't change it from possible because
you're committing yourself to we're
going to do that once we look down this
is the system this was adopted
this was adopted
and
you know once you do this every time we
have a meeting and we agree assistant
and we take a vote on it and then you
come back and say i don't agree with it
because it doesn't suit what since my
boy
right the first amendment uh i'll get
the chief exec to read that one out
whoever proposed and sent it okay if i
if i read out sure our colleagues from
that services will correct me if i'm
wrong so we've got a substantive
proposal from councillor hudson seconded
by councillor newton and that's to
accept the recommendations uh in the
paper then we had a proposal from
councillor crady uh to take out capstone
paths and put in victoria park and that
was seconded by councillor haines
we then had a proposal by council
brenton that was to take out cats down
paths and san diego road and put in
torrent and pioneer market and victoria
park
so the second recommendation is
a bit wider than councillor craigie and
councillor games his proposal so i don't
know whether councillor craigie and
councillor page are willing to
accept the wider proposal
or or we take them
proposal individually would be fine but
if we don't go for it then i'd like to
back up
okay so on that on that basis then if we
uh take a vote on the amendment to take
out canstdown parks
and capstone paths and replace that with
victoria park
and that was proposed by council craig
he's certainly back councillor hayes
and the show of hands all those in favor
of that pre-show
so it's the first amendment and proposed
by councillor craig it's efforted by
councillor haynes that cadstown paths
are removed and victoria park is put
instead
in the list of pits that you've got in
front of your page 39.
so all those in favor of that proposal
please show
that's two three four all those against
so that's lost that's lost and the
second one
and can all those
against please show again then
we've got a countdown
[Music]
second second amendment was proposed by
councillor bretton
yes you have some character in the chair
first of all um with the capstone uh
access
uh my correct insight this building
[Music]
designed by torridge wasn't it put it by
torridge correct
refresh my memory yes thank you i'll be
sure about that
but why the hell do we get it wrong in
terms of disabled access parking then
how did that work
changes in all these years how come it
suddenly becomes now an urgent matter
well that's not your discussing tonight
cancer
can you have to make it up
okay
so the the second amendment was from
councillor brenton seconded by
councillor cottlepenkin and that was to
take out paid c200 which is catstown
pass c 2 204 which was sandy mia road
and replace those with torrents and
penny market and victoria park
[Music]
okay so all those in favor of that
amendment please show
all those against that amendment
and twenty two again
thank you right now the substantiate
book
which councillor hodgson proposed and
accounts the new concept
that we
accept the recommendation on page 40 of
your agenda
no i'm moving to the vault i'm sorry i'm
moving to the vote
i'm moving i'm moving to the vote on
that please which you had agreed you
couldn't take that i'm sorry cancer
catalan
i'll move into the vote on that now
please
all those in favor of that proposal to
cancel the odds and secondly by cancer
and newton
accepting the recommendations on page 40
please show
[Music]
goes against
that's 22 4 and 7 again
22 4 and 7 again thank you for that
right all right we'll move on now to
item
nine
pete hudson's been sat there very big
patiently
it's treasure it's the treasury
management report and capital strategy
on pages 42 to 16. thankfully
thank you chad
[Music]
so this is the report of
treasury management and capital strategy
um which is a statutory requirement that
we um
set a treasury management report for the
following year and a capitalism strategy
so
i'm not going to go into too much detail
and it's all there in the world the
appendices but in
basically in summary we
within the reports contain the treasury
management strategy for the following
year and there's also appendix with our
current council party list so all the
investments
that we place and we also have the
potential indicators primarily showing
us arts or um
the statistics of where our borrowing
is authorized limits and operation type
boundaries etcetera and we have a
mrp
policy which is about our money per side
to pay debt and finally we've got the
capital strategy
so really key heights uh key highlights
contained within reports and many key
points
[Music]
um interest rates
stayed low although they started to rise
and expected to rise slightly
we currently have four million pounds
and placed in ethical investments which
was um
part of the treasury policy we set out
in the last year
and
one other point to know is that during
the last year we have actually exceeded
our county party limits with our north
bank and this is down to
um the global pandemic and grants we've
had we've had um
over 57 million in grants paying out to
local businesses
um over the global pandemic and this is
meant that we've gone over our even
empowered with our local home bank
so i think that's all i'm really
proposing to say at this point so we can
move on to the recommendations
um
so recommendations are that the council
approves the treasury
management and investment strategy
and including the counterparty list the
potential indicators and minimum revenue
provision policy
and also according to the capital
strategy
thank you
okay
um councillor james you're proposing
that
thank you
counsellor
[Music]
thank you oh my god right it's been
moved and seconded that we accept the
recommendations on page 43
all those in favor please share
any against
you against
any abstentions
one extension
for one abstention 28 41 abstentions
thank you very much everybody
our finances
for their clear
thank proposals for the thank you